[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça n'a pas mal fait alors on en est où
écoute on avance comme en mal j'ai
l'impression un salaire c'est dingue
il est sûr à canoë et sait pas sur
quelle rive droite c'est pas la vie quoi
ils doivent également des machines
est ce que parce que j'ai vu tout le
monde dansait est ce que je voulais
donner mon avis bien sûr
alors ici tu sais je vais te dire on n'a
pas peur des langues de bois je peux
dire il n'a pas de langue de bois si tu
veux dire quelque chose sur quelqu'un
qu'est-ce qu'a trouvé alors va dire à
commencer par toi mathieu et moqueur oui
[Applaudissements]
franchement les deux c'était très chaud
et vous mettiez une tartine elles
sortent eygliers à lavéra star gris
parler d'eux mêmes tu as aimé à la
maxime maxime et genève mais c'est mon
droit du scratch et n'a pas elle n'a pas
aimé et que je la comprends